all right shine
shy where did you grow up where you from
fort worth texas
and tell me about your family growing up
you had both your mom and dad
yeah how would how would you describe
your childhood
horrible what kind of stuff was going on
my parents always argue all the time
i really didn't go to childhood i didn't
really have a childhood because like
my mom would get into it with her and
with my grandparents on my dad's side
so then we're packing up our stuff and
moving to waco to her family to her mom
and dad
or to her mom and then a month later
we're moving back to
back to fort worth and it went like that
until i was nine
and then my mom divorced my dad
and my my life just got worse ever since
any abuse any time i was abused every
day
through my whole childhood like what
kind of abuse
well my mom was allowing my stepdad to
molest me and meet me
for everything
how old were you when this started none
did you go on for a while so i was 17.
oh geez
did you tell your mom yeah but then she
didn't believe me and then when i
i asked her when i got older i said why
didn't you believe me when
i told you what was happening to me she
said well somebody has to work
i said so someone has to worry you can't
protect your child you can protect your
only daughter
she's like no somebody had to work
what happened when you left home
i tried to get back in contact with my
mom and everything
they did like i wanted to go getting
pregnant had three kids
and every man i'll get with they was
always doing the same thing
beating on me for other people's
mistakes or whatever i was always
playing for everything
so then um
i had my daughter in 2009 my last baby
and my mom weighed into my took my
daughter away from me when she was nine
months old
and my baby daddy was in on it but i
could took my daughter
and wouldn't bring her back home
i haven't seen my kids in 12 years
so then i moved to vegas
because i got tired of my family so i
moved to vegas
in 2016
i was there for maybe i got there in
february august the third was the worst
day of my life
i've met somebody on the
there's a live links i was talking to
and he got me a motherboard uh to
actually take it
to his spot and i went
and started drinking and smoking weeds
i wanted to stay there for three days
after the third day i was trying to
leave and he wouldn't let me leave
that's when i started being abused or
hate
for two and a half years
this is the guy you met through the
internet from
live links is there like a dating site
or something like that
do they still have it on tv
it is not supposed to be and uh
i managed to get away but for two and a
half years
i was 290 pounds in 2016.
when i left made it to uh march
21st of 2019
i was dead
my eyes was rolled in the back of my
head and i got scars all over my body
i was hit with a cell phone charger
everything
i got this yard tape print on my head on
my forehead
i got right here in my head all my head
is where i was hit with a broke spray
can
where he busted the bottom of the head
on my head
and i'm the one out here suffering and
everything
while he's in prison literally having a
room
having a bed food three meals a day each
hour everything
and i don't have that
every time i get into trying to get into
a relationship i can't
because i have flashbacks of what he's
done
and then i the detectives called my mom
and
my auntie and i still you know told them
we're gonna get her a plane ticket
took back to the house go back home
so it's time to go to court and my
family don't want me
i don't even have a family
i fall alone my kids don't even want me
do you have three kids and they're with
who my mom she took her
she doesn't she has them illegally
i've been praying for 12 years
can't i even have proof that she has
them illegally but the police was on her
side
everything she has everybody in texas on
her side
i don't have nobody to fight for me i
have a lawyer
but he even he was even fighting
but he's not strong enough to fight for
against the
police and the judges in texas so i
hadn't seen my kids
at all my daughter don't know who i am
so i have adopted son i got a little
uh 16 month old baby that that i've been
taking care of since he was two months
old
he's with you right now he's in vegas
with his
uh with his dad and his grandma
that's the only baby i ever think about
and he said he would just really
keep me alive if it wasn't for him
i wouldn't be here
because i'm tired of feeling like that i
shouldn't have to feel like things
i shouldn't feel like i'm ugly and [ __ ]
because i know i'm not but i feel like i
ain't going to disclose
why do you think your family pushed you
away
they've been pushing me away since i was
a kid
there was always the black sheep of the
family
i was blamed for everything no matter
what it was i was blamed for everything
my mama didn't even want to have me i
was
i was finally told when i got a little
bit older
my uh my auntie told me and she goes you
know your mom wasn't even wanting to
keep you when she was pregnant with you
she was trying to take abortion pills
with you
tried to get rid of you so i already
knew my mom
never cared about me at all who was your
dad
my brother killed him
my brother killed my dad on the uh
christmas night
in 2014.
they tried to tell me my dad was on life
support
and uh
i knew my dad was okay i knew my daddy
would have made it
just enough for me to come insane and
everything
but my brother told me i'll call you
back in 10 minutes
that was the worst is ten minutes phone
cookie ever had i thought i was gonna be
happy and good news you know yeah
daddy's gonna be okay no
i got the news oh i just pulled a plug
on my own daddy
on christmas
like my dad was my world
like i wouldn't be going through a video
because my dad was alive
but now i just i feel like if it wasn't
for my
my adopted son cue i feel like i
wouldn't even be here
because i don't have nobody to live for
but him he's all he would
how long have you been homeless
12 years because i can't get my own
department i can't get no
place of my own because i don't make
enough money
i'm surprised they let you adopt a child
if you're homeless
no it's it's not through no adoption
agency
it's more or less so i took him away
from his mom
i lived there and took care of this
little boy myself
like she never took care of me
like i bought everything for this baby
he thought he knows me as his mom
he doesn't even know his real mom even
though he's right there
he doesn't even go to her at all when
she picks him up
he screams bloody murder until i pick
him up
like this baby don't even really want
like not know her at all like that and
i wish it were it was different but
it's not because he needs to know who
his real mom is
even though she's there right there all
the time he needs to know
that i'm not your mom she is that's what
i would do
but he won't listen if he thinks i'm too
small because i'm the one taking care of
him ever since he was two months old
like this woman never got up changed
teen fame or nothing
she just let him cry
so i did what i had to do to get and
take care of him
that's the only thing that's keeping me
around that's why he didn't keep me
alive
and i'm in california because i got
tired of having to watch my back
every time i turn around in vegas
because of the dude that kidnapped me
he had his family and his friends
looking for me
now you would say in vegas why do you
think he wanted to kill you
because he told me when he had me held
and everything happened and everything
that if you get away
i will have your family killed he said
but
if you do get away i will come after you
if i go to prison just believe i'm not
going to be there long
i'm going to get out and i'm going to
come and kill you
so i already know he's gonna be looking
for me so i get online all the time and
look up
the prison he's in just to see if he's
still in prison or not
because i'm so scared but vegas don't
care
they didn't help me try to get me into
hop into housing or nothing
they just left me out like they don't
care
being homeless is not easy and i
get disability but it's not enough to
get an apartment
you can have two times the rent plus the
deposit
plus you pay up the price applications
and all that
i can't even have low income housing how
do you
support yourself my disability money
which is not very much
are drugs a part of your life yeah
i started doing drugs at 13.
you think that might be part of the
reason your family
no because my friend my family didn't i
wasn't even doing drugs and when i was a
teenager
i can't believe nobody knew i was even
doing drugs at all
because i kept it a secret i kept it
away from people people didn't even
never see nothing like my kids my kids
never even seen me do drugs
at all never like i made sure i kept
that private
at all times i didn't never let nobody
know
it's just now my what does everything
i've been through i just basically just
gave up like
forget it i was just tired
what drugs do you use today crystal meth
and it is the only thing that's helping
me not to
to lash out and try to commit suicide
as long as i'm smoking on that you know
they don't i don't think about anything
else
i don't think about running out in front
of a car i don't
think about jumping off of a bridge or
get a knife and slice my own throat i
don't think about that when i'm getting
high
have you had suicidal thoughts before
yes my exes actually i just got out of
the
mental hospital before i came to cali
in june i got up june 17th
because my ex called and told him that i
was trying to commit suicide
by jumping in front of a car going 50 to
70 miles an hour
because i got so tired
because i'm tired nobody knows how much
pain i'm in
all day every day
it's horrible i don't i wish there was
no way i could feel this pain in my life
and i'm talking about the broken bones
fractured bones
my ear i'm deaf in one here now
from being beat so bad in my left ear
that he he made me go deaf
my whole face never told me i need to
have surgery on my face
because he broke my all my whole all my
whole all this is all broke
like he just he messed me up
and he even told me i'm gonna disfigure
if i don't kill you
if you don't die i'm gonna disfigure you
but nobody can
vote you but he did
because everybody every time i tried to
relationship
they're always talking about you're too
much you complain too much
all you do is complain that you're
hurting this and that
what am i supposed to do i can't deal
with this pain
i got gashes in the top of my head from
the spray can
this this deed i didn't know he wouldn't
let me go to the hospital for
i had to get the three staples in my
head
people talking about you can't remember
nothing you're stupid you
what's wrong with you nobody don't
understand why
why i'm like this i used to not be like
this
nobody don't understand
all i want to do now is try to help
women
to make them not to know the signs what
to look for
don't just go to somebody just don't go
to somebody's house
talk to them for a while before you do
anything
this was a lesson for me
do you have anyone in your life that you
consider a friend
yeah i got a best friend since fifth
grade
and she had to get the news that i was
walking around the store with a known
killer
she was looking for me for two and a
half years my own family wasn't even
looking for me
i could have been dead nobody knows my
best friend
jackie she was the only one looking for
me
so now like if she doesn't hear from me
in like a
month or two she'll call my phone or
she'll try to get a hold of me on my
facebook
just to see if i'm okay
because she doesn't want that to happen
to me anymore
because she's what i had to get the
pictures of what i look like
they sent her pictures of my face
my arm she said they sent her pictures
of me laying in the hospital bed dead
i couldn't believe it i said no they did
it
she said yeah they sent me a picture of
you dead in the hospital bed
is this the uh the lowest point of your
life right now
yeah i won't be i want to get off the
streets i want to get off the field i
want an apartment or a house
i used to have everything i had i tell
everybody i had a house i had a car
i had my kids i had everything i was
never like
this is not me
i never had to worry about that i never
had to worry about
where my grandma go get my next meal
from
i never had to worry about anything but
i didn't worry about nobody stealing my
clothes
they weren't worried about toting a
backpack with clothes in it
or portable chargers or anything like
that
that was like
this is horrible
like i go to my friend's house and just
just just down and get some sleep just
to take a shower
and i don't ask my friends for nothing
to eat because i'm really ashamed too
i'm sorry i do like when i go to my
friend's house or whatever
to take a shower or whatever just to
chill with them
i'm so ashamed of myself i don't ask for
nothing to eat i would literally go
without even eating for three or four
days because i'm too ashamed to ask for
anything
where do you stay now
nowhere you're just on the street i'll
go get on the bus or
get on the train go wherever
i have no chance no nothing i asked him
i asked a friend of mine because he had
some tents
and uh he goes yeah i can give you one
and then uh something happened
i don't know what i wound up leaving
and when i came back all his hands was
used by somebody else
i was like well i don't have a tent now
it happens like that to me all the time
someone says they're gonna give me some
i don't count on it because it never
happens just like someone told me
yesterday oh i gotta
i'm gonna get you an apartment
yeah right i don't believe you
because i've been lied to you so much
you've been through so much what do you
think is the main cause of your
situation today
my mom your mom
i've been going through this my entire
life
i haven't had a good life at all
like i cannot count on one hand
of how many good days i've had
at all like i don't even spend stuff
spend money on myself like i don't even
have an id to get a motel room
i have to call one of my friends hey can
you give me can you i'll give you if i
give you the money can you get people to
fill room
and then they get an attitude guess what
the motels are never in
they can kick me right out even though i
pay for it
because if it takes me it's gonna take
me it's gonna take for me to get my id
i gotta get one id with one name on it
and get another id with my other name on
it
because i have two names for my birth
certificate
because i had to get my name changed for
the kidnapping
so the way the dude doesn't find me
like nobody understands what my life is
now like my life
it was horrible when i was growing up
but it's even worse now like i don't
even want to be
alive but i got this 16 month old baby
that i adore
that i care about so much
so that's the only thing that's keeping
me alive
and if i can get me an apartment or
something
i'm bringing him home
i already told his dad if i give me i
said i told his daddy if i go
i'm gonna go to cali i'm gonna move to
cali i'm gonna try to get me an
apartment over
there and what i do i'm bringing my baby
home
that's my baby that's my son
his mama don't want him
he goes well yeah he's yours
[Music]
sorry what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
don't go to um like if you meet somebody
like on a dating site or whatever just
because you talk to them on the phone
for 30 minutes and they're wanting to
meet with you and everything don't go to
no
if you go anywhere do not go to no motel
if they tell you they live in a motel do
not go
don't go because they're not
it could be bad
all right shy well thank you so much for
sharing your story
i can send you some places that might
help you with housing so
maybe you can get some a roof over your
head
all right john thank you very much